born into comedy literally you see his
mother mitzi shore was the owner of the
comedy store in la a club where some of
the biggest comedy icons came from but
his comedic style is like no other
[Applause]
your name would be pinocchio
father when can i leave to be on my own
i've got the whole world to see link and
i are cruising the mountain bro we
figure we use a little jew ooze no we
sing the jokes if you haven't guessed it
by now you might need to wheeze a little
juice
cause paulie shore is that guy
whether you've seen or heard him on some
of his most iconic roles we gotta admit
it all kind of leads back to las vegas
my next guest on my show
is bruno
michael jackson
[Music]
his company truly spans of generations
and now he's bringing it back with a new
one-man show we're so excited to welcome
polly shore
what a trip down where's all the claps
come on guys
katy perry's out at some pool in the
middle of nowhere i'm actually
physically here she got a key i got a
bagel from bagel mania across the street
wish him smear hi
it's so good to have you i know nice to
see you oh my goodness so you guys sorry
i'm not wearing shorts
i have no pants i have no pants they're
very short
i just came from fremont street what
were you doing there i was drinking
strawberry daiquiris this is gonna be
the best interview ever
i got shorts i'm just kidding that video
with you and bruno mars yeah i know it's
crazy little bruno mars have you seen
him i tried to get a told him i said
dude i'm the one that set up your career
and he won't he won't call me back what
is up with you i know it's amazing right
you give the guy a break i bring him on
mtv and then he you know what i mean he
gave me tickets to his show i sat in the
nosebleed section it's so it's so funny
just to have you here in person because
your comedy your comedy does span the
generations and it's funny you hear some
of the clips and some of the younger
people see you
in the goofy movie and and they're like
pinocchio the pinocchio oh and oh my
gosh and then of course
i remember you from mtv yes now
when are you would you ever go back to
mtv and do anything i'm doing a lot of
stuff with them recently i just did the
ridiculousness yeah which is that show
that's a clip show
you know where they they do like goofy
clips and then i also i'm doing cribs
actually this sunday at my house in
vegas they're going to come to your
house and check out your crib they're
coming to my house this sunday so
we'll see i mean mtv is my family so you
know i've been there my whole life and
it's like you know going back there is
like
it's like visiting um you know
my alma mater is that a word
of course do you think that the
you're funny because of your jeans where
you came from or the environment in
which you grew up in
it's probably because i love taco bell
no i'm just kidding no i don't know
comedy isn't one of those i mean yes i
grew up in it but my i have i have two
brothers a sister they didn't get into
it so like i i just i've always loved
making people happy and making them
laugh and i get off on it so like you
know my brother's like why do you still
chew her i'm like because i love
you i love showing up and making people
laugh so i don't know it's my thing
unlike what i'm doing right here
normally i make people laugh we are
laughing what tell us about this one man
show that you have going on the one
one-man show's pretty cool it's called
stick with the dancing because that's
what my mom said to me um after she saw
me perform for the first time you know
she's like stick with the dancing
because i end up with pop blocking but
it's basically stories about my
childhood so for instance everyone
a lot of people know the mtv they know
the son-in-law and all that stuff but
they don't know my childhood so this is
all about stories about my childhood
what are some of the the standouts for
you i i mean the softball with some i
went i played little league with bob
dylan's son
you know so i grew up in beverly hills
okay yeah so i went to beverly hills
high school i um
i don't know i mean there's a long list
of things um i stole frozen bananas and
hot dogs from michael bay
the director because he used to well he
used to work the phrase he used to work
the hot dog stand at the beach some of
my friends used to steal from him oh my
god and then like you know when you're a
kid yeah and you're like
you know and then he punched me in the
stomach
and uh
and that was fun and then i dated
charles bronson's daughter oh that was
pretty interesting i mean the list keeps
going and going but it's on my one-man
show which is why i'm doing it because
people seem to be interested in it and
now where where are you doing this and
how do people get tickets i'm doing it
all over
arts district at the wise guys which is
a comedy club down there and i'm there
this weekend and then also tomorrow
night i'll be at the tiki the tiki
lounge uh what is it called the tiki bar
the golden tiki yes the golden tiki i'll
be there with my band called the
crusties now the krusty's are great you
have to look them up on youtube because
this is you guys performing some
classics i saw i saw a video of you guys
performing the classic uh whole song
yeah celebrity skin yeah and you were
really good well you know i'm an actor
so i i commit you know it's like i'm
committing to this interview you know
what i mean so no i just you know
singing is very hard for me it's not
something that comes easy so as an actor
i'm acting like i'm a singer and that's
why i commit but you don't do it in a
jokey way you are right i'm really
committed i'm trying yeah it's hard it's
hard one of your classic movies that i
loved was biodome
any any way we'd ever see a bio dome too
it's happening it is happening it's
happening you know
you and stephen baldwin
you're kidding me yeah is this breaking
news oh my gosh well no it's all over
the internet and basically started i was
excited it's all over so
we're we're working it out now with the
producer at brachavoy
and um we got the story we got the
writer and um and now we're just looking
for some cash
so if anyone's got any cash can we can
we get some cash together around here
we're going to make it happen because
people are calling for it yeah
such a fan and you're hilarious and
we're so happy you're a local you're
you're here i'm not going to be a local
after this interview i'm going back to
l.a no yeah everyone made me feel
uncomfortable around here no come on
let's go no no
we love him where's the claps i don't
hear the clown
okay i'm going to stay i'm going to stay
i'm telling you i live close to which is
hilarious as nicholas cage
your neighbors yeah i'd like to i'd like
to talk about my relationship with
nicholas gage but unfortunately he made
me sign an nda oh no
i'm hilarious i want to see the hoa
hilarious is that that i made me sign a
piece of paper and you didn't i can't
talk about anything we talk about really
yeah you just talked about it
yeah but i'm not saying anything in the
conversations we had
do you want to nope
paulie shore stick with the dancing can
you show me a couple of moves before we
go live uh comedy club june 17th 18th
20th july 18th for tickets go to
paulieshore.com and then tomorrow night
i'll be at the golden tiki with the
crossties and his uh head is going to
get shrunken okay what are your moves i
don't know we're just cruising where's
that song
where's that where's that song you're
the kind of girl that has the time to
look around oh my gosh
all right now it's getting awkward we
gotta go they're gonna check it out it's
gonna be really awkward
thank you papa you're amazing let's
check in with rocky